he's the bantamweight UFC champion of
the world we flew him all the way from
New York to Calabasas California it's Al
Jermaine Sterling on this week's food
truck Diaries and I'm feeding them
Gordo's Hot Chicken let's go
[Music]
[Music]
the champ in the rain Mr Sterling what's
up brother what's up how you doing a
little wet out here dog you know that's
what we do for a living you're from New
York though the weather out there is not
great
that's okay right now it's actually nice
it's not too cold yet but um it's
getting there getting a little gloomy
out it hasn't snowed now with your uh
Championship status the champ status I
mean you've been a champ are we thinking
of staying in New York or what are we
doing here well I'm still in Vegas I
split my time half of the year uh Vegas
uh tax reasons smart obviously the
weather is always shining out in Vegas
yeah it could get a little gloomy in New
York but I still love New York that's
where home is got family out there
um
friends all that good stuff but I'm
going to be splitting most of my time
over in Vegas yeah now life for the uh
The champ is pretty good my man life is
good right now life is good and I feel
what's interesting about you I feel like
you were kind of like I don't say hated
you would feed into it a little bit and
get some hate back because with the the
Peter yon fight where you know he lost
on DQ and then in the rematch which I
had you win in that fight I didn't have
a period win that fight there was like
this kind of animosity towards you a
little bit like oh he's not the champ
but you definitely were and then you
even Double Down posted like with the
belt and [ __ ] which I love right and
then I feel like with this TJ Dillashaw
fight it was one of your first fights
where you weren't the heel anymore like
you weren't the bad guy everyone's like
yeah I'll join the champ get them you
know so I feel like the tide is turned
now do you feel that or no a little bit
I still feel like the tj5 was like
villain versus villain I still feel like
like when we walked out to the
ceremonial weigh-ins he got booed I got
booed it was like a mixer between chairs
I don't understand like where I sit with
the fans anymore but if you talk [ __ ] I
engage with you you give me positivity I
engage with you yes I've been doing that
since the beginning of my career yeah
you have I love it you know that's what
the fans get from this sport it's not
like the NBA where you get no access
whatsoever I'm gonna talk to you I'm
gonna reason with you man good or bad
and I don't care that's just how I am
some people think I do too much but
let me have fun the way I want to have
fun don't tell me how I should live my
life yeah also these these fans like I
don't get the backlash too it's like
well Peter you didn't make Peter Young
illegally meet you in the face you
didn't I mean you just did your job in
the rematch and controlled him the whole
time had his back it's a dangerous dude
man the most dangerous yeah I still
think he's one of the most dangerous
guys and I had to nullify him the way I
had another Farm yeah I wasn't mad at it
at all and I I was impressed with Peter
Young able to kind of navigate the
waters like when you have that's your
ship when you have someone's back like
they're usually screwed so for him to
for you to have that control that many
rounds which I don't see the argument
how it was controversial in any faster
yeah and it was four takedowns four
takedowns guys correct if your hands
touch the mat that's a takedown college
wrestling rules so they say two for 22 4
for 22 but who's counting right no it's
definitely a win and then how do you
feel about with yawn uh in his fight
against Sean O'Malley before you answer
going into it how did you see that going
down I didn't know I felt like both guys
had the ability to starch each other
like it's a Striker versus Striker
matchup both for the super high level
you can see Yan connecting early putting
him down and breaking a guy who's never
actually been tested yet and then you
can see the other side of it guy long
ranging and he's very good and very
accurate with his shots and he does a
good job of Faking where he'll throw
something and then come back with
another combination and just put put it
right on your chin and sit guys down and
did you did you think it was too much
too soon for sugar no no he really
hasn't like you know that's the online
Chatters oh he hasn't beat anybody good
you know he fought Cheeto right you
fight Pedro Munoz that didn't go his way
nah I think in the same realm of skill
set both guys are super high level what
we didn't know about sugar was is he as
tough as he can be when he's being a
hammer whether or not he's going to beat
a nail and I give respect and credit
Warriors dude I thought he did a
phenomenal job of going into the fight I
had questions about how tough he was and
he showed like he took the shots he
weathered the storm came back he sure he
belongs exactly Jody belongs to he's the
top three guy that ranked number one now
he's not all cupcake you know it's not a
little cupcake it's not don't let that
tie-dye hair fool you man that boy can
fight exactly you can [ __ ] fight did
you have him win the fight so when I
wash it in the back room I'm getting
ready for my fight and uh oh so you
probably can't pay that much attention
yeah I'm still warming up but it's
getting me ready for my fight because
I'm like this is potentially who I'm
fighting next and uh not in a sense of
like a winning or loss but it's gonna
dictate a lot you know so I want to see
what's going to happen
and uh just kind of letting me get a
refresher and how to remember certain
cues like whether or not they're faking
or footwork so I like to look at things
like that while I'm in the back warming
up as well
I watched the fights and it'll just
rhyme me up a little bit in a good place
in a good way so in the back I had John
winning edging out in a close fight I
thought John rounds one and two and uh
on Molly three but I went back and I
watched it on my podcast and I broke it
down I did like a whole fight review and
I scored it and I was like oh Molly won
the fight
I'm Molly won the fight the exact same
thing so I was I was gonna uh fight
companion in Salt Lake City because I
was on tour so we did one in the green
room with Frank Mayer and Jesse on fire
this was the three of us and I was
drinking and it's tough for me to pay
attention like I'll see certain things
and I would see like young get taken I'm
like ah damn because I was rooting for
sugar obviously yeah and I see all this
stuff and then we go round by round and
at the end of it I go okay how do you
guys score it and Frank and Jesse on
fire who's an MMA head they're like oh
yawn won that are they like sugar won
that fight like really I feel like Peter
I was like don't quote me on that I saw
the control of the takedown so I'd
probably give to Peter and then when I
saw the Twitter talk coming on and
people were like I have sugar two to
three I'm like oh she might have won
this thing then we announced them we
just went nuts yeah and uh so I was like
man I gotta re-watch it went back and
rewatched it I had I had sugar edging
out that first round second round Peter
all day third round sugar all day yeah
so two three and uh yeah with myself in
that rematch same thing he starts off
slow even though he tried to be more
aggressive but it's three rounds he gets
behind on points and the same thing I
said like breaking down that fight I
said it's going to come down to who
could score early and obali was able to
score more even though he got to take
down the takedown wasn't devastating
because he landed on his hands remember
sugar got to take down the first round
too yeah the round end with him taking
him down exactly and with the takedowns
you gotta what did you do with it if I
took you down and slammed your ass on
the ground okay that's bonus points see
the difference but also the difference
we were like oh well Al Jermaine when
you when you took down Peter you know
you didn't finish him and you weren't
laying big shots punch that [ __ ]
up punch also controlled him the entire
time yeah on his back is the most
dominated position besides Mount like
that's considered winning the round yeah
just to take down and do nothing with it
it's and the guys landed more
significant shots I always give that guy
the rant yeah if I take you down in the
street and I held you down like Matt
Sarah did that guy at the at the
restaurant I'm just holding down
laughing as you're bucking up and trying
to move and I'm just giggling like ah
look at you it's so cute yeah like what
do you think is happening right now you
can't do anything and when you get in
the car if your boys are like you won
that man yeah you know never you're not
gonna say this guy oh you didn't do
anything yeah I crushed your back yeah
you did nothing about it so so that
leads me to this for your next fight and
I actually like where where your head's
at what I see on Twitter and in the
headlines I like that you're not rushing
back into fighting because of your camps
but looking at the land kind of the
landscape I would assume especially for
you you want the most money possible the
biggest name and a good fight to me
that's sugar he checks all those boxes
because you can get you know if you
you're a paper you guy and you want
points suga's bringing the audience out
of all the names I can offer you sugar
is by far your biggest name that's what
I would think but then I'm hearing the
other side that people think it's sayudo
based on his accolades but I'm like the
guy has a phone in almost three years
and it seems like no one cares in my
personal opinion like what I see but I
could be completely wrong I don't think
you're wrong I I think and and so I love
sahuda there's no shade here at all but
if you're comparing as far as like a
numbers wise so who does the sugar
Sugar's current he's coming out that
huge Peter John win yeah to me that
equals numbers and Pluto's not going
anywhere and I like to eat yeah that's
what we want I want that for you and I
want that for sure I love both you guys
I think it's a great style matchup sugar
should get paid viewpoints as well so I
will give him that that notion because
he will be driving that as well and I
think anymore no I know anyone review
card if you're on the pay-per-view card
you're on a pay-per-view card for a
reason right yes so I think you should
be getting some type of cut from that
you don't have to you shouldn't always
have to be the champ in order to get
points or reminds me at all or anything
yes agree so um I like that matchup and
sugar could go out there he could beat
me he could start to me catch me early I
could take him down and make it a quick
night it's one of those matchups where I
could go drastically one way or
drastically the other way so I think he
still has a chance it's a great fight I
think I think it'd be good for you I
think you do have more fans on your side
now after that TJ Dillashaw fight I
think you're out there more and like
you're such a good dude the people that
hate onions can be tough to hate on me
now I think you've showed your true
skill set after you know the fights of
Peter yawn the fight with TJ and then
with Suga and his fan base to me that's
gangbuster we going Sizzler yeah you're
buying that Adventure door you know what
I'm saying let me feed you because I
could talk to you all day let me feed
you some hot chicken from my friends at
Gordo's all right and then we'll we'll
dry off and go inside Chef it up
that's what I got in here
[Music]
how you doing brother how are you good
to see you again man thank you for
having us again I got a champ for you
this time perfect and he doesn't have a
fight coming up for a while so we can
eat perfect Gordo can you know what you
want uh I'm looking at the number three
combo three that's looking like That's a
classic that's gonna be money and I'll
do the mac and cheese perfect perfect
one three finger what spice bro we got
anywhere from no spice mild regular
spicy to Gordo killer that's right
spicy stuff I do but that's more my
fiance so I do the amount I do mild is a
lot yeah I don't want to pay for it
later yeah you don't pay for it on that
six hour flight planes Act of New York
I'll do the number one number one and
I'll I'll do it spicy not the Gordo
spicy I'm not trying to have issues
either perfect perfect and then can I
also uh do the the chicken tenders yeah
of course yeah the combo too yeah and
those spicy as well yep perfect and then
we'll also throw in a loaded fries so
you guys could try it out as well okay
might as well man push ourselves today
perfect you want you want to throw in
like two extra Tenders in there too of
course
yeah I don't got to make weight right
now you know it's perfect perfect
you're gonna be fine at 55 you keep
hanging out with me man that super fight
I'm already 170 pounds everyone's like
oh you should fight February I'm like
you think I want to do that wake up
right now no oh we'll get to that that
drives me nuts that drives me nuts yeah
you were shred bill on that scale you
look jacked it's a hefty weight cut yeah
you look good though
all right two three fingers that's it
brother thank you so much thank you
thank you that's Gordo himself dog
[ __ ] the man that's Gordo himself
[Music]
let's take a little break from Chow my
boy the champ Al Joe my boy it's never
too early to play holiday music it's
never too early to start thinking about
the gifts for your friend especially
your bro friends all right we got you
guys because we're all worried about
below the waist there we're all thinking
about it we're worried if you have a
bush how that's gonna go over so listen
my friends at manscape got you covered
with the lawnmower 4.0 to avoid another
silent night in the bedroom all right
then added manscape's top of the line
shower products that have the people
thinking All I Want For Christmas Is You
Baby Santa cares about his sack and so
should you look nice when you get
naughty and get free shipping with 20
off by going to manscape.com get that
manscape Platinum 4.0 package it's a
One-Stop shop for dudes who deserve it
all all right it has everything you need
to help you Deck the Halls from face to
balls just in time for the mistletoe see
Seasons the Platinum package has
everything in it they got the best
selling performance package plus Ultra
Premium body wash Ultra Premium two in
one shampoo conditioner premium
deodorant all right you get the
lawnmower 4.0 you get the freaking uh
nose and ear Wacker treatment we got you
guys covered and you get the crop
reviver Tone Ball deodorant and you get
a little thing to put it all into a
little
um freaking bag to put all your goodies
in all right manscaped is the One Stop
Shop what else you're going to use quit
making your nuts quit bleeding for no
reason it has a flashlight you can do it
in the shower whenever you're ready to
go all you got to do is get 20 off and
free shipping at medscape.com
that's 20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com manscape get your jingle
balls ready for the holidays this
episode of the food truck Dives my boy
Al Joe is brought to you by the best
Kratom on the planet listen if you want
to get focused you want to quit using
all this other stuff that that you don't
know if it works and you're worried
about I don't know I've heard some
things about Kratom but I don't know if
it actually works well you got to use
one brand one brand only we're talking
about happy hippo and when you visit
happyhippo.com use promo code thick boy
you get 20 off for life you use that
code as many times you want to share
with your friends your aunt your cousins
your nephews I don't care who it is if
you're thinking about using Kratom
there's only one brand that's Happy
Hippo happyhippo.com they have the shots
they got the gels they got the gummies
they got the pills the powders we got it
all and you can trust them happy hippo I
use the cherry flavored really
concentrated Kratom shot before I do any
show so visit happy hippo be like your
boy visit happyhippo.com use promo code
thick way 20 stop for life now let's get
back to the program all right my man
let's this looks pretty messy
yes you were the right colored clothing
if this does get messy I do have a white
shirt but whatever man I'm fat so it's
an excuse let's do it dude what the deed
has to be done it does we have to get
into this man now Gordo's one of my
favorite because it's all in the bun
dude it's on the bun New York you guys
have good food so you know what I'm
talking about oh yes but I don't eat the
green stuff so I should have told them
to hold the coleslaw and all that but
you don't eat anything green barely
that's how I stay so ripped you know
okay that's good
some of my favorites
if so messy my mind's so hot
that's why I got the tenders a little
spicy a little bit easier like so spicy
um I made a mistake
professional though I'll get through it
um
yeah cause
you don't have a fight coming up so we
can eat like this but this is how you
should be eating now for a championship
fight got another Ruby on the Belt
doing your thing having a little fun
playing with celebrities in L.A doing
the damn thing man
what do you think about fighting I think
it's funny
right because they they're like Oh Henry
sahuto Al Jermaine and what was it
February in Australia
and I think you I think on Twitter you
put kick rocks what happened I'll be
ready in June which is hilarious
um
I don't think people realize like they
watched the TJ fight and they see you
dominate and like oh he's healthy he's
ready to get back in there it's like no
you don't see the cam the camping for
you to cut to uh 135 like people don't
realize the amount and the the the
beating your body takes going through
those camps and the guys I train with
yeah so yeah like you're saying the
camps are tough
I'm going with Killers When Rob Duvall
is really
it's not an easy out for anybody as I
can show you video what is coming of him
sparring with this guy
he'll do three rounds this guy's done on
the floor laying down takes his gloves
off he might not even take his gloves
off he's just laying down trying to get
air
and then he'll go spar with this guy and
then he'll go to the spot with another
guy and he'll look around and his just
be like is there nobody left no no it's
not Rob there's none left we're trying
to chill dude and that's who I'm
sparring with you know so and what's his
what's his definition where is he from
Georgia the country of Georgia that
whole area that layer scares me all of
it they're just Savages I got some
high-level training Partners man Dennis
bazukia I had JP bass helping me down
when I was in Vegas giving me that TJ
does show look yeah did a great job with
that Murad was there for the pressure
but with marab it's uh I mean he's
commented yeah like winter is coming Rob
is coming oh yeah so it's only a matter
of time have you guys talked about the
cold it's a cold storm he's gonna it's a
cold storm yeah cold hairy storm have
you guys talked about like so hairy it's
so hairy all right have you guys talked
about that
um it's different when you're training
Partners like I don't like when train
Partners have to fight each other but if
it's for a belt then we're talking about
life changing for for both of you guys
yeah so that's when it gets dicey
100
um
we've talked about it not like a little
question I mean is it awkward it's not
awkward it's just like
it's not a real reality until he's like
there where they're like okay he's the
next guy we're gonna give the shot to
then it's like okay we need to really
figure out what the hell we're gonna do
um before this fight it was kind of like
dude I could go out there and I could
lose to TJ and then the door is wide
open for him and I would help him the
same way he's been helping me so there's
that but obviously now I've won so that
puts him obviously in a weird spot and
that's just the reality of it
um it was also about the performance
because you know how the UFC works if he
went out there and killed Jose Aldo he's
next in line 100 but then it's like all
right morale we need to figure out what
we're gonna do am I going to go up are
you going to go down
um
are we gonna secretly do an interim
title yeah yeah yeah yeah
and am I going to be injured yeah
am I gonna take a little break you're
wrong you said break while you figure
this out no but I like your mentality
like that's my deal with it when it
comes yeah yeah you have enough things
to worry about right now do when it
comes because you know you got guys like
obviously Henderson who wants that fight
um you talk about taking a break I think
it's funny too because the fans don't
understand unless you're close to the
sport
it's usually not to fight yeah there's
some Wars which you know that there's a
reason why the commissions give it a
six-month suspension but your fight even
with TJ it was the camp that did it so
you deserve that rest and also being
champ you don't be too active as a champ
you know there's because you know you're
fighting The Best of the Best
if you were to lose a fight now that I
think you're gonna lose but if you're
gonna lose the fight then you're getting
you know you're not getting pay-per-view
points are getting the same recognition
so there's a lot that goes when you're a
champ based on what fights you're going
to take so you gotta be smart about that
but it's also with like and I would love
your stance on this with TJ Dillashaw
who's my boy I'll be completely I love
TJ yeah we have been we have the same
coach that's my guy yeah that's my guy
I'm biased as [ __ ] when I make picks
like I hate I hate picking against
anybody but TJ's a legit friend of mine
and he trains my old uh coach uh at
least they're bowling and you know
people are so upset at TJ because
they're like you know he came out after
the fight was like you know I had one
shoulder it kept popping out in Camp
everyone's like oh you robbed us of this
fight stuff like that here's my and he
pulled out laundry list quick from his
crotch yeah I mean he was hurt though
right but the this isn't any disrespect
towards you I don't that's a tough map
there's a reason why the the the
oddsmakers had to use a favorite not
knowing that he had one shoulder like
you're you're the best in the world for
a reason so that was a tough fight
whether TJ had three arms two arms one
arm I don't care about that but the
backlash that TJ's getting I think it
just you know obviously because him
popping hot for PDS that it just gets me
to another reason like oh you robbed
this on a fight you should have pulled
out of that fight having one shoulder
but you don't get to that level and and
not think you can't win a fight based
off an injury you just exactly and I
think it's hard for just regular people
that go on you have one arm why would
you rob this dude TJ he didn't become
world champion of the bandwid division
by you know taking the easy way out like
he literally thought all right it did
pop out in Camp but I'm still winning
rounds maybe I won't field as much when
I get in there unfortunately goes in
there throws that kick you take him now
he posts his arm it pops out and then
you just Molly [ __ ] him which was so rude
there's a little respectful well I was
like Jesus the mouth the entire first
round I give TJ credit for sticking it
out and being tough and allow me to
give him the lickings that he deserved
yeah that's fair like he allowed me to
punch him because most guys in that
position would have just tapped out and
find a way to cover up or just lift
their neck up like I'm defending but
yeah
or the wave it off so they don't take
damage and then it doesn't solidify you
really like I like that TJ was like he's
a manifest is what it is we both talk
[ __ ] and he was a man about it took his
lickings like a man
um but to say like two shoulders or
three or four would have changed the
fight I'm like that is my best position
you're not turning into my guard you're
not escaping and shrimping I get that
body lock triangle on just about anybody
even if they're heavier weight losses I
Sparrow bigger guys
again get them in that position they
usually end up on bottom when the
round's over or like if it was a fight
and was sparring I'm punching the ground
out you're not even getting out of this
position and the sparring section has to
stop and then we start back on the feet
no I I think I mean when you get
somebody's back and you know you have
their back like that even you know these
outliers who are you know 80cc Champs
and stuff like that I think you're the
best in the world on somebody's back
thank you I mean look what you've done a
number of guys Santa Hagen a number of
these dudes you know somebody's back
that's why
I earned more respect for Peter young to
have you on his back that long defend
him like people have no idea how hard
that is to defend yeah you know Jan was
smart though because he did a two-in-one
just about the entire time or he clamped
down on my wrist not allowing me to pull
my arms up when I had the wrist control
that's smart it kills the time saves him
from any punishment yeah saves them from
me advancing to a mount position where I
could punch him out like I was starting
to do and then he rolled through and
then I had to change the positioning and
uh from there I had his back and it's a
little bit harder to do damage in that
position especially when they're holding
the wrist but you're winning but you're
winning so people that were complaining
about that one too it's just like you
guys don't even understand what's
actually going on it's such a high level
chess magic that makes one mistake it's
over the fight's over it's over if TJ
has two good arms he thinks he can now
shrimp and turn to stand up he gives up
his neck correct he gives up a
guillotine choke he's compromised
situations that we trul we drilled over
and over and over that I'm like this is
going to be game over if we end up in
this position it's Checkmate you're also
the best in the world at like straight
up like you get somebody's back like
it's a world like I'm sure whether it's
you know sugar Hennessey like don't let
him get your back man thank you do not
let this guy you're back yeah it's um
did you have any animosity towards TJ
when you heard when he's like I had one
shoulder not animosity but I was a
little I was a little tight I was like
yo that's a [ __ ] move bro because you
came at me the entire training camp
saying you're building in excuses I'm
like dude I'm saying what I think is
possible I think that there's a real
life possibility that you're cheating
still yeah and you're finding another
way to get around it as per your team
has said they disclose this that he was
cheating for since like pretty I think
they said like College college wrestling
he came over and was showing these guys
how to like do the dosing or whatever so
your teammate said it's not me so like
take that up with them with your your
former teammates yeah and then is that
like Cody Garber and stuff the boys from
alpha male yeah yeah I think all that
with a grain of salt though that but
then but then there's other people
within that realm who've also said the
same gotcha so then from them like well
where the smoke is fired they can't all
be lying and just all hate TJ yeah to
that to that extent where they're just
gonna make [ __ ] up yeah so I'm like well
there's a possibility that he might be
cheating so I gotta consider that but at
the same time like I thought other guys
who probably were cheating and it
doesn't matter 100 I take my loss like a
man I take my win like a man and that's
it you know I may be parading around but
after you finish somebody you want to
have a little fun let that out you
burned it 10 weeks eight weeks however
long the train came in so you Jewish if
us TJ just didn't say anything
you wish like he was just like just took
the loss you say the better man won
tonight yeah when Jan was kicking my ass
in in that first fight I I said what
happened I said I made a miscalculation
but that's on me it's not John's fault
it's my fault I take full responsibility
he was starting to kick my ass later in
the fight and it was pretty it was
getting very very one-sided yeah you
could say my punches weren't effective
but it was starting I was still working
yeah but I wasn't going to quit I wasn't
gonna roll over I took my beating like a
man and I was trying to still find a way
to win the fight and I said he was
better that night but he made a mistake
and it gave me an opportunity to do it
the right way and then the rest is
history so for him
say whatever you want about the shoulder
but I guarantee you you are winning
sparring sessions and it gave you the
confidence to go I can win this fight
that's what he's saying he was he was
like everyone upset at me he was like
inspiring I I was fine I was winning I
was beating world-class guys exactly on
my shoulders compromised so that's why
I'm not mad that he said that because he
he to his point was like no don't get a
Twist up I'm still a world-class fighter
even though my shoulder was quote
unquote injured and algebrae still beat
me Sterling still beat me even with this
one shoulder you know I agree I just
think the way he said it came off like a
little sour but you can understand why
he would still take the fight even with
one shoulder his age like at my point to
it was like all right it sucked he had
one shoulder you know shoulder blew out
but at his age like the chances of him
which is a Redemption story chance of
him getting back to this point if he
pulled out are not good there's so many
monsters looming in those shadows in the
bantamweight division so he has to take
advantage of it and he legit in his head
thought he could beat you yeah legit and
that's why I try to explain to people
I'm like I I go through these training
camps with injuries and I have to decide
whether or not I want to continue and if
I get through the sparring sessions that
man I could get through the fight yep so
if you got through spawn sessions you
probably thought he could win the fight
I mean that's like Francis and Gano his
last fight against Sarah gone ACL he
blew out his ACL couldn't walk spark
couldn't do any training he called
Kamara Usman to tell him they're close
she called Camaro Camaro's like bro I
haven't been able to run in years like
I've had training camps where but my
knees were so bad or my shoulder was so
bad I couldn't even spark I couldn't
trade nothing he's like but mentally I
still went in there known I could win
he's thinking I found a way to win he's
like so don't let this be a reasonable
fight so if every fighter disclosed
their injuries every time I think the
fans would be shocked yeah it's very
rare fighter goes into Camp full health
these guys the fans sometimes they could
be a little Relentless because they
don't understand like this is our
livelihood we need to put food on the
table yes we need to provide for our
families especially when you have a
little one like TJ does so I respect him
as that and family man like I don't need
to discredit him and un like the stuff
that he's done and accomplished to Big
myself up I can give credit where it's
due one of the best to ever do it
exactly you beat him and I think he
wholeheartedly thought he could beat me
the way he was and then I I didn't like
how he kind of [ __ ] on garbrandt
saying like I beat him with two blown
out shoulders I'm like okay well if you
beat him with two blown out shows don't
make the excuse now that your shoulder's
been coming out and you lost that makes
sense at the end of the day you lost
let's just take it take the L yeah like
I'm gonna come back better
rehab and just go yeah I think for tj2
knowing him like he's such a Savage and
training camp he's put so many miles on
him on himself during training camps I'm
gonna say the PD's probably played a
little bit of a factor maybe you know
yeah
I Gotta Throw it in I just disappear
about like the meme I just did the
homelessness yeah yeah just into the
bushes no I think uh but he goes so hard
in the paint it's like these injuries
are catching up with him like Corey
Santa get blew out his knee beat him and
he remember he beat Corey sanity in
Wendy listen if you haven't started
shopping yet I got the perfect gift for
you guys out there guys and gals all
right wireless earbuds are expensive and
listen my ears are all messed up so you
need some that fit maybe you got small
ears large ears my friends at raycon got
the perfect gift and right now you can
shop early skip the stress snack some of
the best deals of the season on
something everyone will love we're
talking about premium audio products
from raycon when you're looking for a
gift for everyone all right you're
looking for stocking stuffer raycons are
the way to go their wireless earbuds are
the only earbuds I can put in my
freaking weird ears their headphones and
speakers their premium sound useful
features they also custom all right
comfortable fit and up to 54 hours of
battery life all right we got you guys
covered plus raycon makes it easy with
holiday gift guides for everyone in your
life Dads Moms co-workers maybe there's
some girl you want to impress get her
this cool gift all right right now go to
buy raycon.com shop schab get 20 off
site-wide the entire site twinks off any
raycon product which never happens so
don't miss out all right to save big and
Shop stress free this holiday season or
saving bigger and get three percent off
raycons exclusive holiday bundles when
you bundle it in more than one thing
bump them together get 30 off that's
byracon.com shop for twinks off your
recon purchase buy raycon.com shop list
we all want to get in that zone we all
want to be productive you want your
brain firing at the highest capabilities
that's why you need nootropics but not
just any nootropics you need Alpha Brain
from my friends at Onyx my brother from
another mother comedian podcaster Joe
Rogan says it helps them form better
sentences when he's talking now listen
it's nootropics and you're like yeah but
I'm very sensitive to caffeine and
caffeine free and I'm so damn sure of
their Alpha Brain you get your money
back no refund necessary you get your
money back you can keep the bottle tell
them why you didn't like it it's not fit
for you but you're gonna love it but no
return necessary keep it keep it that's
not sure they're gonna love it man you
guys are gonna love Alpha Brain and you
can save to yourself the entire audit
website on kettlebells steel Club Macy's
workout gear workout nutrition we're
talking protein powder protein bites
Warrior bars Alpha Brain everything 10
off or you can go to Walmart just pick
up Alpha Brain Pelt your boy out here
help your boy out save ten percent off
by going to audit.com FTD all right or
swing by your local Walmart and pick
some up today but use on it.com FTD and
save 10 off Alpha Brain the best
nootropic on the planet from my friends
that on it you know what I'm saying yeah
get you some man it's time to celebrate
I'm gonna take a little bit of this I
know we put some in here already but I'm
gonna put like a full glass in for you
sure just want to make sure you get the
full spectrum there show the guys this
is so hot try a little bit oh Christ I
mean I'm trying to hold it together over
here
I'm gonna I'm gonna use an excuse too if
this interview goes bad I'm like man
that the same I'm blaming on the
sandwich I'm just gonna take the easy
way out but the sandwich was too hot I
blew out my I think this is actually my
third time so Cheers Cheers brother good
to see you again man yeah you too
brother the champ
yeah smooth Daddy yeah it is it actually
is really smooth products I didn't know
what to expect to be 100 there's a lot
of people out there with alcohol could
get a little dicey yeah there's nothing
worse when your friend creates an
alkalines like try it not Ariel
smooth it's smooth yeah good
um I don't want to announce your stuff
until too early but I'm excited for some
stuff you have in the works a little
entrepreneur yourself man I'm trying
you're a beast I'm trying to make a rum
right now so hopefully when I go down to
Jamaica we can find a company that can
do the bottling and Distilling for us
and then just keep it more authentic my
grandparents my parents are both from
Jamaica so I would like to keep my ties
to that country and I like it because
it's authentic too because a lot of
people you see a lot of celebrities
whoever they are but I came up with a
vodka or a tequila it's like you didn't
drink that stuff yeah but just do it for
the money you know what I'm saying that
so that never works out but back to
fighting so
TJ fight you look phenomenal I mean best
body abandon weight we've seen a hot
second you know not to get weird on you
but uh you look jacked as hell in that
so now you're sitting back if you want
to see you fight uh the we talked about
the fedware yeah in February not
happening so kick rocks to as you said
um you know so for you to maybe fight in
June
you know there's you got the Henry
cejudos of the world right any interest
in Henry sahuto
see here's my stance with so you know I
feel like no one really cares or
something Die Hard fans but I could be
completely wrong
tough competitor I think would be a
tough fight secret fighter I do think I
will have the the recognizable on TV
size Advantage I think in person I think
you'll see the physicality yeah he keeps
talking about this wrestling background
I'm like well that doesn't have any real
bearing on the fight
when you have another high level
wrestler I mean if we had a wrestling
match I'm like so you know how badly do
you think you would win or how badly
would you actually lose like what do you
actually think would happen if we just
straight up Russell you know but yeah my
only pushback for that and tell me if
I'm completely wrong because I don't
have a wrestling background I wrestle
for a long time but not at your love
especially not here pseudo's level you
know I think being a Olympic champion
you know and uh competing at the Olympic
level a little different than Collegiate
level right some outliers like bow
nickel you know like there's the
outliers yeah freestyle
folks.wrestling is what I did in college
and high school gotcha Henry didn't do
focused on College he did freestyle
freestyle he went right to the Olympics
yeah so it's a little different style
that's why my back riding pause
is high level
because we wrestle want to talk we're
allowed to wrestle in the top position
get those legs in yep and that's why I
think if we wrestled
I'd beat him
depending on the style that we competed
in or
if we fight like what does he do to win
he keeps saying all this like what do
you do do you keep it standing are you
gonna try to knock me out yeah
probably have an advance on this I
probably chew my food first right sorry
you know breaking up if I definitely
have an advantage on the feet all day
yeah but he thinks I think for him his
mental toughness is the most impressive
thing that's what makes him an outlier
him in DC just they don't quit exactly
they're Savages when it comes to that
but it would be a tough fight but I
think I have a lot more tools to win
where for him I think his tool of
winning is he needs to get me in a tough
spot so he can learn heavy damage I mean
how much shots do I actually take in my
fights discrediting the the yawn fight
like if you don't include that one where
I said like my rehydration process felt
like I was still cutting weight in the
in the middle like during the fight from
the beginning of the day till the fight
yeah everyone is the Marlin fight right
that was it that's it so that could
happen one shot I don't give a [ __ ] and
I me not paying Marlin any mine and
discrediting at him and then making a
shitty mistake and just rushing in and
you know you're supposed to have those
fight day nerves that fight didn't have
that I just kind of went in there super
cocky between millions and I got humbled
especially yeah yeah so that's good for
you that's what allowed you to be champ
now when you need that to happen yeah so
that made me better in the sense of my
mental preparation and I learned like
you got to check your attitude and your
ego at the door whenever you step into
that [ __ ] at your level yeah yeah
there's big prices that you have to pay
and switch your brain cells you know so
I learned from that Marlon was better
that night and hats off to him uh but
with Henry I look at it like what would
be your advantages to winning and I have
to be honest with myself my skill set in
his and to be fair
he beat Dominic Cruz coming off the
couch Dominic Cruz took a great
opportunity to fight for a world title
and short notice correct so it was like
who wouldn't take the opportunity you
got a crazy pay bump right you got a
chance to possibly become a champion and
that means you get pay-per-view points
if you do win who's not taking that
chance like let's let's uh call it what
it is and he said to me if you make that
choice to step into the octagon that's
on you so I go okay so TJ made the same
decision to step into the Octagon that's
on him right yeah so we have to but
still we still have to assess these
differences in these fights these these
uh variables so I go okay you had a
fight that went that way based on this I
do think if you fought Dominic Cruz
where he is now before the Cheeto
knockout obviously I think it's a
different fight yes because yeah now
he's got his feet wet he's been more
active but he's also at the uh upper
echelon of his career but I think a
different fight for sure exactly what
I'm not saying he still wins I still I
still think Henry probably still wins
the fight yeah but it is what it is
Henry won and you can't take that away
from the guy on paper would you say in
order for Henry to to fight you probably
need a win over uh I don't think sugar
would fight him I don't think you have
to do that to Sugar any fight anybody
just any Cheeto anyone show the fans
you're serious show me you're serious
because I'm just like I I look at him
and I can't take him serious I really
can't and there's no disrespect no I get
it I think because you know he is silly
on there he talks a lot of [ __ ] and I'm
silly too you're silly too as they call
cringe yeah
I said Thank you to somebody they told
me that was cringe
I was like this you guys just take
Fringe for anything it's overused now
yeah you guys wanted yeah
that's out
um yes I I think for Henry if you were
to get a win over I can see that but I
think too sometimes people don't take
him serious like when I had vocalypse in
here and remember him too was talking
[ __ ] to volkanovsky and I was and he
just shed a light on this and I was like
oh my God you're so right because I was
like on the in the interview I was like
you know what do you think come off Big
Win what do you what do you think about
um you know fighting Henry sudo he's
like bro I don't want to answer that
he's not even the testing pool so he's
talking all this [ __ ] and he's not even
a like I don't entertain it because he's
it's not real until he goes through that
then I'll entertain it and I was like
he's not intensible he's like no bro so
he's six months out I'm still fighting
two to three months I might entertain it
it's not an option I was like oh I
didn't think of that so I think Henry
Sue was asked for all these fights
before right but he it wasn't a legit
option option because he was in the
testing pool now he's back in there I'm
interesting what to see what the UFC
wants to do I heard the UFC from sources
really wanted you versus sahudo but uh
if I'm you it just again it's a numbers
thing it's a it's a you know it's a you
want the biggest fight possible Sugar's
the bigger fight I'll show you the
biggest fight there's a lot of hype on
sugar right now right I like sugar tits
you know I think he's a very well
renowned guy I think he's talented he's
doing a lot of things outside of
fighting which makes him super popular I
don't they compare him with Connor which
I don't get he's kind of like funny and
witty I feel like sugar is more like
silly like he does his stuff where he's
smoking weed he Shadow Boxing with one
glove arms the other hand's blown
smoking The Joint two they're completely
different maybe I guess the comparison
because he makes a lot of money there's
knockout oh she can have a ton of
knockers but especially at Connor's
level but there's also maybe a
similarity because he makes so much
money outside of the Octagon but outside
that they can be more opposite yeah
there's nothing similar whatsoever
you're the most rich yeah I they compare
an O'Connor I'm like it's the weirdest
comparison because Conor is actually a
funny [ __ ] like because sugar
Sugar's just like he does he does silly
things that I just find funny yeah he's
a cool dude yes yeah shrink is great but
I think that's a big fight and I think
if I'm gonna be champ
I'm gonna take the fight where because I
could lose the next fight I could go on
a crazy skin and lose the next three or
four it's a business brother that's how
it goes it's a business and it's a
business move and it's no shade on him
sahuda he's such a not done with Sammy
Sue is such a Savage and deserves all
the respect but if I'm in the business
of Al Joe the business move is sugar as
far as you know getting viewership
pay-per-view buys the magnitude of the
fight everyone's tuning to see what
sugar is next and you yeah you know what
I'm saying if we're gonna get into the
thick of it
Molly fight and Dana said it I think he
didn't think I was gonna do what I was
gonna do and then obviously he didn't
know what was going to happen with TJ in
his pre-existing injury or whatever and
I don't think he thought O'Malley was
going to win so he probably thought they
could at least do the trilogy with
myself and they they thought they had
really good options and I don't know
what the difference is now I still think
it's a good fight I still think a lot of
people will tune into it just like with
myself and O'Malley oh 100 it's the
biggest biggest fight they can make they
know that yeah they're just playing
Hardball they know that which I don't we
all [ __ ] know this so I just don't
get it like if you think of Molly can
win he's gonna definitely do the work
he's got Augusto
um taquinho Mendez who I fought also
um 80cc world champion and I beat him in
like the grappling department for the
most majority of the fight he did go for
a leg lock he tries to say I gravitated
and grab a [ __ ] cage but uh I beat
the guy over 15 minutes you know so
um that's his trading partner that's his
trading partner who still competes in
Jiu Jitsu and he's got a good guy to
like reference for like back control and
things like that so that would be an
interesting it's an interesting fight
and I don't necessarily want to fight in
June it was just a month I threw out
there it was like before that if you
just don't want to fight February yeah I
don't want to travel one that's one I'm
being completely honest with the with
the viewers I don't want to travel again
to spend 20 grand plus just to go to an
overseas fight and make all the
accommodations right it's imperf no I go
to visit here's my yeah 100 Australia
that's fantastic here's the thing my
thing with that as a champion they
should come to you you're it should be
where the [ __ ] you want the fight at it
doesn't make sense when I hear Champions
going to Abu Dhabi and England Australia
if you're the champ unless that's your
backyard I'm like nah dog they can meet
me in Vegas yeah it should be set up for
me I've earned this status where it
should be set up so I have the most
um comfort possible you know what I'm
saying and I'm not opposed to fighting
in Australia it's just I just did an
overseas fight do I want to do that all
over again two weeks getting there
getting acclimated and doing all that
it's kind of weight there's a lot that
goes into it so it's like and for me to
cut 35 pounds again and people are going
to call me a weight bully I'm like
everyone Cuts away bro [ __ ] relies
I'm like I'm too small for 45 but I can
go up and compete with some of those
guys doesn't mean I'm gonna be the best
in the world at 45 right now I'm the
best in the world at 135 so it's like
I'm gonna weigh my options I'm like I
don't want to do that yoyo to my body
because I do think there's negative
effects and I want to make sure I'm
enjoying my life I want to make sure I'm
setting up the things that I need to set
up so that when I'm done I'm 33 I'm not
a 21 year old bull anymore yeah I got
injuries I tweaked my rib beating the
[ __ ] out of TJ I don't know how I don't
know how late in that night yeah just
having my figure four yeah and the way I
was twisting those punches I woke up I
will not woke up later that night I was
like dude what the [ __ ] happened like
how do I tear like the ligament or
something in the ribs there I got the
x-rayed nothing was torn just sore just
sore so I guess that's just it thank God
so um that was that will heal up in time
I haven't trained yet and uh at the end
of the day it's all about maximizing
your time in the sun yep you know so if
anyone doesn't understand that think
about it like that if you have a job
opportunity you're going to make sure
you can maximize that opportunity if
it's a small window like I said I could
lose my next fight and then pay-per-view
points are gone out the window thanks
for coming pat on the ass correct we'll
see you next time let us know when you
want to come down you have no leverage
that's it you know and freaking Tijuana
or some [ __ ] around fights all day long
yeah
it's a different Beast man so I I got a
little bit of injuries I got to take
care of I got this partial partially
torn bicep tendon that I have I got to
get that rehab get this thing stronger
and how's the neck the neck's way better
night and day thank God I wish I did it
earlier yeah because it would have saved
me a lot of pain and Agony going through
these those training camps that I had in
the beginning of my UFC career yeah and
I got through them but eventually the
straw that broke the cameras back was me
getting slammed on My Head by John and
then uh uh what was the other one the
fight ending knee yep you know and yeah
so it is what it is man and and uh going
to John how do you feel John was talking
that he feels disrespected and he feels
like there's something's up with him you
know the the decisions to you losing in
those decisions that decision the split
decision and losing the sugar he's like
I want to take my talent elsewhere
outside the UFC my my whole thing with
that is you know I I I don't want to get
I can feel that way because it's not
like it was a your fight wasn't a
robbery the sugar shop wasn't a Rob
close fights not a Rob it's not like you
beat the hell out of the guy for five
rounds and then it went the opposite way
so the close fight so he can see how
people can allude to that he lost the
fights yeah I don't really understand
his his rationale on that I think it was
right after the fight so maybe he didn't
watch it yet a little emotional yeah
which we all get
and I can see for him you do all that
work the training you make the trip the
sacrifices leaving your family and the
fight doesn't go your way in a close
fight you feel like you've been slighted
but when he goes back and he watches it
if he tries to be outside of himself
which you have to be if you want to
progress
you can see why you lost the fight
correct and I again I thought John won
the fight when I watched in the back
room by a close margin I went back and I
watched it as a judge yep I go by the
scoring criteria I think O'Malley wanted
to agree and for uh Peter Young too it's
also he's still top three in the world
like whoever they give him next I feel
sorry for you know let's go to the
judge's Garden man I feel bad for
whoever he is fighting next like don't
get it twisted just because he lost to
you and he lost the sugar like that guy
is no joke you lose it to the best guys
in the world and he's a nightmare of a
matchup yeah nothing's easy with that
[ __ ] he'd be Corey Sean Hagen in a
five-round war now I don't let me not
call it a war five round fight where he
got strong as the fight went on and
showed his Brilliance and showed why he
was a former champion and um why he's a
threat to anybody in this division or
even in the world he's such a beast he's
such a beast so uh for you you mentioned
145 and we'll get you out after this you
mentioned uh 145 how there'd be no
reason you know you're doing the thing
at 35 that's the best in the world at 35
but it's we're in this day and age of
you know double champ double champ does
that cross your mind to go up to 45 yeah
but this division is so deep it's really
hard to be a double champ because then
it's like when are you going to defend
the 135 pound belt and I can see how
that can be messy I would have to fight
have another quick fight and then I
could be like okay I can make a quick
turnaround go to 45 where I'm not
cutting as much weight it depends how
long you want to fight for because let's
say you fight sugar next let's say it
goes your way you beat sugar then Henry
sudo's there then you clear out those
two you beat Peter yawn right you beat
Corey Santa hey again I could see an
argument there like let's go to 45 for
the big big name fight especially a
vulcanopsy or to beat Mark Chev which is
stuff gay swimming Upstream right there
that's a tough one and I'm not saying
it's impossible but he's definitely
swimming swimming Upstream for that
whenever you're dealing with a 10 pound
weight allowance
I'll get to that fight after that I'd
love your thoughts on that fight yeah
but 45 is that industry at all jumping
up there 100 there's there's a lot of
good fights at 45 for me and I train
with the kid Bryce Mitchell multiple
times I love Bryce and he's a tough dude
he doesn't cut the most weight for 45
which gives me confidence that I could
come in and do some good things at that
weight as well he's tough he's durable
he takes guys down and he makes it look
like almost like effortless what he does
he's undefeated yeah so that gives me
confidence I love to watch you guys
grapple oh it's so fun prices are big
there's there's a couple of good like
footage on us and that's why I like I
get Confidence from things like that so
and then I see these guys doing well
Bryce is such a down-to-earth good dude
such a good kid man such a good dude
yeah well he gets a little wild with
certain things I find funny strong
American the strongest which I buy when
I love but then you can't watch so I'm
like oh we're gonna demonetize
I loved and then he was going after
Rogan for he's like call me a dumbass
for being a flat Earth he's like I
challenge you to debate I'm like Bryce
you don't want these problems bro yeah
like debating Rogan's a bad idea of my
man especially on Flat Earth yeah Rogan
comes prepared yes which I don't even
know how he has time to do all that
research because I don't have the time
to do that [ __ ] and his stuff it's not
like you're just researching you know a
fighter coming up or something like that
like I mean he's sitting down with like
Jordan Peterson and Elon Musk and [ __ ]
like he's just a different level man
what's that astronaut guy
um the black dude oh uh Neil deGrasse
yeah yeah yeah so super smart the fact
that Joe knows half of those things I'm
like dude you were 10 times smarter than
I probably ever will be or have time to
be maybe when I'm done fighting I can
learn the way he does with uh I would
like to be uh positive and say we could
both get there because he's just a freak
man he's just he knows something about
everything yeah which is he just down he
just the way he downloads data and then
can regretation his own Express and you
know the way he can do it yeah it's just
like I've never seen it he's like he's
so good yeah and then I like have a a
point and then like you know he'll stump
like Neil deGrasse like Jesus Christ
does yeah where me I just like [ __ ] Mars
bro yeah talk to us about Mars that's it
that's all that's it like yeah that's
all you got for you but um 145 would be
interesting I think there's a lot of
good fights and I just watched live
thick too yeah what was uh the kid who
just won um Brennan no Arnold Allen
Arnold Allen he's my Dark Horse oh for
that division this guy's scary you guys
yeah you guys are prom well you did to
cater and I know there's a little bit of
an injury whatever but he was pretty
much on cruise control hooker too yeah I
think he's a problem yeah I think I know
his dad's a strong man yeah dad's a
strong win yeah so that'll be a tough
fight man so there's a there's a lot of
challenges out there right that's fun
dude that's scary for me to watch yeah
yeah horrible I mean I'm like this fight
might hurt it's fun
I might be in the hospital after this
one no yeah so yeah but as far as uh
again I keep saying we're in on this but
I would promise I know this but as far
as Mark Chev and uh volkanasi I you know
I I can see ways maybe volcanov's can
pull it off you know
um on the outside with this kicks being
issue he'll have speed Advantage I do
think people will be surprised how
strong volcanovsky is that dude is a
tank used to be 220 pounds yeah like
First Team all thick yeah I don't know
if it gets back thick I'll sponsor
refuse to get fat so he uh you know I
think he'll have some speed advantages I
think technique-wise when it comes to
wrestling and boxing you know with Mark
jump him going forward
um I I think stamina is going to be a
cardio is going to be on volkanovsky's
side it's just I was never that high on
machev like everyone told me how good he
was and I hate when people tell me how
good of guys I'm like I'm not seeing it
yet brother best of all time like I'm
not seeing it yeah and then when I saw
what he did against Charles Oliver I was
like yeah sure you guys went
bullshitting this dude is good yeah yeah
you hear me running champ for quite some
time if he wants to be yeah he can be
um yeah tough fight I think the
stylistic matchup I think the speed the
faint of volcanovsky he does this like
level change thing where it's so subtle
but quick twitch movements yeah and he
does he will do that inside leg kick
utilize that and he'll just keep
touching keep touching kind of get you
to a little bit frustrated pull out your
attack and then he'll be able to tie you
up
um or he'll land that one two that he
does it so well uh he's a small dude so
he punches up yeah um but he does a
great job of doing that his timing is
always on point uh his cardio is
ridiculous he impressed me with the Aldo
fight how to shut him down
systematically I was just like man Aldo
had nothing for him like no answers
after just coming off these highlight
real Knockouts even Max Holloway yeah
like when they did that one I I told him
I said I think you need to get over that
Max Holloway hump because he has such a
big fan base yeah in order to get that
put that behind you like you just gotta
beat him he's like yep they want to do
it we're down do it then he did it and
to me that wasn't like a weathered Max
Holloway like I I think it was more a
product of that's how [ __ ] good Alex
volkanovsky is yeah so it's not like Max
Hollow he's that bad that [ __ ]
is a Savage yeah people have a hard time
differentiating between that like
correct they won't give the credit where
it's due like they'll say like maybe
something was off with this guy when
it's like no [ __ ] this guy's
just actually that guy is that night is
that good so yeah I think that's a very
interesting fight I think the size
Advantage would definitely play towards
marketev I think obviously but the
wrestling yeah but I haven't seen nobody
hold volkanovski down like whatsoever
he's explosive never he's built like a
fire hydrant unless they get on his back
I mean we haven't seen that yet I know
guys I know guys pretty good at getting
on bats yeah I know a guy who's really
good at get taken bags yeah so that's in
the world oh yeah that's in the UFC man
I'm excited for that hopefully they do
make it happen and I think there's
nothing wrong with someone chasing
greatness and again for me I always try
to build people up because this is such
a brutal sport in the sense of like
you're here one day out of sight out of
mind the next minute you know and uh you
could be on a high and one day you could
go on this crazy losing streak and just
be done so I like to see these guys
within a top capitalized when they can
capitalize on and hopefully they could
go out there and
um impress if he doesn't win yeah but
it's an interesting fight if I had to be
honest I'd take
moccasive believe it now me too yeah
he's a Savage yeah I'm like oh dear God
polkanovski please you know I love
okanovsky yeah but you know these dagger
stadiums are coming man and they're big
they're famous Georgians Georgians your
boy Rob and I appreciate could be
recognizing what I do when I take guys
down and that top pressure situation it
could be say something it was like I'm
the best in the world in this position
this is where I pretty much Excel and uh
doesn't say that just a hater yeah they
just say I'm just holding I'm like all
right let me let me do this to you and
see what happens but also khabib says
that the guy knows a thing or two about
control yeah you know what I'm saying
yeah so I mean you got big things you
know that to me it's like yeah I'm I'm
you know I'm an outside looking I'm
proud of you man you're doing all this
stuff outside that gun but when you look
at your career you know the Peter John
uh fights you look what you did against
TJ Dillashaw and you look what you have
coming up with a Suga Henry sahudo you
got Cheeto Vera looming back there so
you have an opportunity just like kind
of set yourself apart from all of it man
all right the skill set to beat all of
them
I mean the only guys I haven't fought
that that I have fought that weren't
rank whereas taquinho Mendes and I think
that was really it I think everybody
else I thought was right you know
everybody else was in within that top 15
so I think there should be some credit
do or given um I think that'd be at like
number six pound per pound rankings I
don't know I look at it when it's there
but I don't like even pay that anymore
also how you know because if it was
legit then just the heaviest guy in the
world beat number yeah you tell me what
can I see him beat up Francis yeah well
I guess they say a pound profound if you
were the same size who would win based
on skills I think that's how they do it
no that is it's stupid
I do have to say though I did listen to
the podcast so you know you gave TJ a
lot of props you know remember he's my
voice
no you should you should he's my boy you
know what the problem is now the problem
is now is because this is your third
time on the show but you know this like
you're one of my favorites and also you
got a great podcast you do anything TJ's
a close friend yeah so my whole thing my
whole pitch on that right when I do the
show my whole nid on that is like this
is why you should root for TJ because
it's a comeback story like we all love a
comeback story and you're like cool
story check this out and then beat the
show out my friend and now you're here
and he's not yeah but you know I love
the [ __ ] you matter of fact I love you
so much you know I always ask my boys at
suplex to send a pair of shoes uh for
all the fighters on food truck and I
said dude we got we got aljo coming on
he's champ like we know who he is I'm
like cool be less sensitive but I was
like I need a special shoe man and this
is a shoe I couldn't I'm trying to think
who we've had on who's champ uh maybe
Izzy but that was years ago for oh we
had Francis on but he wore like a size
19. so yeah he got a weird shoe yeah you
got like a giant Ugg Boot and I'm like I
drew a Nike sign on no he got some cool
shoes but these are these are made for a
champ and this just says uh Mr Sterling
uh big fans here at the shop being that
you're the World Champ we figure it's
only appropriate we laced you with these
World Champ dunks please wear and enjoy
they gotta be the only dunks that come
with a championship belt diamond
encrusted oh look at that and it's snake
skin for skinning the snake
bro I didn't even think of that hashtag
skin to snake baby look at that suplex a
champion shoe for a champion that's
lined with some purple in there I like
the purple you know bad boys are hard to
come by my very first t-shirt that I
made when I first started was uh purple
and lime green love it which is what I'm
wrapping my Tesla
yeah it's gonna be midnight purple with
lime green like the action marks on it
and uh this is this is dope so I
appreciate you guys thank you guys Focus
what's the company uh suplex thank you
you're not too far from there but these
shoes man so there you go man we can try
and find a 13 I said I'm not World chat
man just send these were Al Joe is this
is it like a name for these like a
Edition yeah these are the the Nike Dunk
glow retro World Champs I swear they got
World Champs literally the Nike dope low
retro World Champs one of one uh one on
one for you I mean I listen if you're
not a world champion you can't wear them
so just like food you're the best
brother appreciate it keep doing your
thing man
I'm gonna try I'm not I'm not I'm never
and now you're not fighting TJ anymore
you know he's probably not getting back
there I'm never gonna pick against you
you got my word I'm a believer I'm an
aljo believer I love you you know this I
like this champ shoes though I like when
people pick against me because it makes
me work that much harder yeah I do like
it yeah yeah you really beat the [ __ ]
out some guys well that's the champ Al
Joe we love you man thanks guys
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding